im november 2013 verpasst petra prado
aus nürnberg einen anruf ihrer schwester
heidi dannhäuser hätte dieser moment
alles ändern können gab es damals noch
eine chance ein unglück zu verhindern es
ist einer dieser momente die manche
menschen nie wieder loslassen
ich habe
mein name ist khan und ich führe euch
durch einen fall der bis heute rätsel
aufgibt einen cold case mit mysteriösen
spuren und überraschenden wendungen in
den datenbanken der deutschen polizei
dienststellen gelten aktuell zwischen
9000 und 11.000 personen als vermisst
die meisten fälle werden innerhalb
weniger tage aufgeklärt andere brauchen
wochen monate manche jahre und viele
werden niemals geklärt der fall heidi
dannhäuser ist jetzt seit neun jahren
offen
[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
nürnberg fischbach 2013 heidi dannhäuser
ist damals 49 jahre alt von beruf
postbotin jeder kennt sie jeder mag sie
sie ist zuverlässig und pünktlich in
ihrer freizeit ist die blonde schlanke
frau mit den funkelnden blauen augen
sehr aktiv heidi liebt ihr lauftraining
im nahe gelegenen wald und fährt gerne
rasant motorrad der nürnberger stadtteil
fischbach ist beschaulich zusammen mit
ihrem lebensgefährten freddy genießt
sich von außen betrachtet das leben im
gemeinsamen haus in diesem schlichten
weißen einfamilienhaus wird heidi zum
letzten mal gesehen
in der nacht vom 13 auf den 14 november
2013 verändert sich für heidi und wohl
auch für ihre freunde den partner und
die familie alles heidi dannhäuser
verschwindet spurlos
seitdem ist sie vermisst die ermittler
gehen relativ schnell von einem
verbrechen aus und suchen das opfer die
ermittlungen bringen hunderte spuren zu
tage und führen zu einer überraschenden
wendung
dennoch heidi bleibt bis heute
verschwunden
ihre schwestern stefanie pranger und
petra prado geben über all die jahre
nicht auf stefanie die jüngere von
beiden streicht sich durch den blonden
pagenschnitt und vergräbt dann die hände
in ihrer schwarzen lederjacke sie weint
noch immer jedes mal wenn sie an ihre
schwester denkt
die ältere schwester petra ist gefasster
streicht aber sichtlich nervös ihr
schwarzes kleid glatt
wir haben keine ruhe
die geschwister vermissten hatten zu
heidi und haben auch heute zueinander
ein enges verhältnis sie können nicht
glauben dass heidi einfach so
verschwunden ist
unermüdlich suchen sie nach dem warum
seit dem winter 2013 haben sie nur noch
den einen wunsch dass heidi lebt
[Musik]
lebt heidi vielleicht in spanien dem
land ihrer träume das ja mal besuchte
denn auch dorthin führen spuren und
einer nimmt die fährte heute wieder auf
bild reporter jörg völkerling er trifft
die schwestern in fischbach genau dort
wo heidi zum letzten mal gesehen wurde
ihr schicksal bewegt auch den
gestandenen journalisten unter dem bild
polizei reportern genießt aha glatzkopf
mit dem ernsten blick kultstatus die
berliner redaktion zentrale setzt ihn
oft den brenzligen lagen und den
schwierigsten fällen ein wie kann es
sein dass eine so patente und bekannte
frau wie heidi dannhäuser einfach aus
dem nürnberger stadtteil fischbach
verschwindet wurde die postbotin opfer
eines verbrechens was ist mit heidi
tannhäuser geschehen
[Musik]
ortstermin polizeipräsidium nürnberg
seit neun jahren laufen hier die fäden
zum fall heidi dannhäuser zusammen
unzähligen spuren ist die bayerische
polizei empfiehlt dannhäuser
nachgegangen reporter jörg völkerling
ist mit kriminalhauptkommissar thomas
ringer verabredet trainer ein ermittler
mit kurzen grauen haaren und vollbart
wirkt nachdenklich vor der großen
pinnwand hinter ihm
dort ein foto von heidi die mit ihren
lockigen blonden haaren und dem
fröhlichen schlossen im blick viel
jünger wirkt als 49 unter der pinnwand
zahllose aktenordner grün etikettiert
der gesamte fall der fall hat mich schon
immer bewegt weil ich eben auch von
anfang an dabei war ich werde solange
ich hier in dieser dienststelle in
diesem job macht an diesem fall
dranbleiben das kann ich versichern weil
weil ich mir das auch als lebensaufgabe
geschrieben habe diesen fall zu klären
der fall der beliebten postboten bewegt
aber neben den polizisten auch viele
andere menschen die stadt nürnberg bucht
immer wieder auf eigene kosten eine
werbefläche für ein riesiges vermissten
plakat es prangt dann der ein und
ausfallstraße für spaß der sinn
vielleicht erinnert sich doch noch
jemand beim vorbeifahren sie am 14
november
2013 oder danach gesehen zu haben unter
dem foto der lachenden heidi dannhäuser
steht vermisst heidi wo bist du hinweise
an die nächste polizeidienststelle
das sind nur die spuren
das sind doch die spuren innen sind wir
nachgegangen 130 segert unter 30 sind es
geworden ja aber leider bis jetzt keine
ergebnisse es gab keine andeutung
gegenüber wichtigen bezugspersonen also
sie hatte ja wirklich sehr guten kontakt
zu ihren schwestern und da hat sie
überhaupt nichts durchklingen lassen
dass sie irgendwie das leben satt hat
dass sie keine lust mehr hat auf zu
hause und dass sie weg muss was ist mit
heidi dannhäuser geschehen steckt eine
beziehungstat hinter dem verschwinden
oder ist die 49 jährige heimlich
ausgewandert immerhin den abend des 13
november 2013 kann die polizei anhand
der aussagen des lebensgefährten
rekonstruieren freddy wird sich damals
mit seinem computer beschäftigt haben
nach der arbeit kommt heidi wie immer
nach hause in die kellergasse in
fischbach hier stehen hauptsächlich
einfamilienhäuser man kennt sich hier
vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer
persönlich aber man bekommt alles mit
denn viel ist in dieser gegend sonst
nicht los nachbarn berichten dass freddy
und heidi sich am fraglichen abend wohl
ziemlich lautstark unterhalten es gibt
einige meinungsverschiedenheiten
heidi legt sich nach dem streit
erschöpft auf das sofa im wohnzimmer
freddy setzt sich wieder trotzig an
seinen computer erst spät in der nacht
geht er ins bett und achtet nicht auf
seine partnerin die er auf dem sofa
vermutet doch am nächsten morgen
donnerstag den 14 november 2013 ist
seine lebensgefährtin spurlos
verschwunden er hatte sich auch erstmal
nicht mehr so viel geht an gemacht
sondern sich und seine sache gekümmert
und ist dann aber schon nervös geworden
und hat im wald auf eigene faust nach
ihr gesucht am 15 11 2013 hat er sich
dann dazu bewegt gefühlt anzeige zu
erstatten weil sie dann bis dahin auch
nicht aufgetaucht ist und auch ihre
arbeitsstelle nicht wahrgenommen hat
dies ist uns sehr zuverlässig antritt
schon damals hat heidi schwester petra
ein komisches gefühl
zeitpunkt noch mit freddie zusammen aber
der hat es gekriselt hat es mich immer
anrufen und hat ihr kummer und ihre
sorgen erzählen aber immer wenn er
natürlich nicht da war das hat er immer
heimlich gemacht unmittelbar nachdem der
vermisstenanzeige
gehen die ersten maßnahmen die eine
streife fährt dann unmittelbar zum
wohnanwesen und schaut da nach ersten
spuren bzw hinweise die darauf hindeuten
wo sie hingegangen oder aber es passiert
ist bei ihr war eben ausschlag geben
dass sie ihre arbeitsstelle nicht
wahrgenommen hat das war ein
entscheidendes kriterium zu sagen hier
ist etwas im argen miley ist mal zuhause
nachzuschauen was hat sie denn
hinterlassen was ist da das deutet
darauf hin wo sie hingegangen ist in
diesem fall stand auch zb noch ihr auto
vor der tür
heidis neuer roter golf steht noch da
heidi ist stolz auf ihr fahrzeug und
wenn sie sich hätte absetzen wollen dann
doch wohl mit dem schmucken auto auch im
schlafzimmer fehlt nichts alle
bekleidungsstücke sind dort wo sie
hingehören nichts wurde für eine reise
mitgenommen und das wichtigste auch ihre
handtasche ist noch da
personalausweis aus schlüssel
mobiltelefon petra und stefanie erfahren
schnell vom verschwinden ihrer schwester
kommen sofort nach fischbach und hängen
überall vermisstenanzeigen auf seit dem
14 november 2013 vormittags wird frau
heidi dannhäuser vermisst sie ist 1
meter 64 groß hat blonde schulterlange
haare zuletzt war sie vermutlich mit
einer dunklen jogginghose und weiß rosa
turnschuhen bekleidet da sie joggen
gehen wollte im naturschutzgebiet hunde
park auf höhe der kellergasse vielleicht
ist id nach dem streit gar nicht aufs
sofa sondern lieber zum kopf auslüften
noch eine runde joggen in den wald
gegangen das wohnhaus befindet sich ja
in der nähe des sogenannten lorenzer
reichswald es dort wiederum gibt es den
eisweiher hatte heidi beim laufen
schlicht einen unfall ist sie in der
dunkelheit des novembers unglücklich in
den weiher gestürzt und ertrunken oder
wo die sie beim laufen überfallen und
getötet und später ihr leichnam im wald
versteckt
november 2013 die polizei durchsucht nun
den nahe gelegenen wald an einem
sonnigen wintertag durchkämmen die
beamten zentimeter für zentimeter das
waldgebiet ein spürhund nimmt
tatsächlich heidi dann äußerst fair
tauche steigen daraufhin an diesem
kalten novembertag in den ice feiern
doch alle diese bemühungen führen ins
leere die vermisste bleibt verschwunden
petra erinnert sich an ihr letztes
gespräch mit ihrer schwester
ich habe den anruf an
war mein chef und ich konnte ihn nicht
rangehen und ich habe mir gedacht ich
bin sowieso in einer viertel stunde
fertig und dann rufe ich sie gleich
zurück nach der singstunde ich bin ins
auto und habe sie auch sofort angerufen
aber
da kam die meldung
und dann kam aber kurz danach eine
ein anruf der niemals kommt erscheint
dass sich die spur zu heidi dannhäuser
schon zur nacht des 14 november 2013
verliert die polizei sucht aber weiter
im nahen umfeld nach gründen für ihr
verschwinden hat lebensgefährte freddy
vielleicht doch etwas damit zu tun oder
ist heidi untergetaucht um ein neues
leben ganz woanders zu beginnen eine
spur in diese richtung ist den
ermittlern aufgefallen das einzige was
bekannt wurde dass ist und da haben wir
auch lange mit rein ermittelt dass sie
kurz vorher im urlaub in spanien war und
diese urlaub was sie für sie das größte
wenn der letzten zeit das größte
erlebnis in der letzten zeit und sie hat
sich auch zu ihrem anstehenden
fünfzigsten geburtstag am 24 11 2010
unbedingt geld beziehungsweise
gutscheine gewünscht um die sich diesen
urlaub nach spanien wieder leisten zu
können am 25.11 2013 zehn wollte heidi
ihren geburtstag feiern im keller finden
die beamten bei der hausdurchsuchung
zwischen klären sprudel und bierkästen
reichlich neu gekauften alkohol das ist
der wein und schnaps für ihre große
party zum einsammeln für das reisegeld
nach spanien für die polizei ist das ein
indiz dass ein möglicher selbstmord
unwahrscheinlich ist die sache mit dem
traumland heidis spanien bekommt fünf
jahre nach ihrem verschwinden neues
gewicht ist tauchen weitere indizien auf
die zwangsversteigerung des
einfamilienhauses in der kellergasse in
dem der lebensgefährte freddy bis dato
wohnte bringt einen stein ins rollen
denn seit heidis verschwinden wurden die
raten nicht mehr bezahlt große schulden
sind aufgelaufen
endlich so hofft kommissar ringer tut
sich etwas in diesem aussichtslosen fall
die indizien deuten eher darauf hin dass
sie nicht mehr am leben ist aber dann
würde ich gern haben dass ich da die
sicherheit habe und dass man sagt ja
wohl jetzt haben wir sie gefunden ist
als wissen wo sie ist mit der
versteigerung des hauses haben sich hier
der zusätzliche indizien aber wirklich
nur indizien ergeben die ein verdacht
aufkommen lassen dass die
leiche daher die dann irgendwo auf dem
grundstück in dem haus versteckt es um
welche indizien es sich handelt verrät
kriminalhauptkommissar thomas ringer aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen nicht
welchen status hat der lebensgefährte
bei ihren ermittlungen zu diesem
zeitpunkt war er beschuldigte gegen
freddy wird damals strafrechtlich wegen
totschlags ermittelt wir hatten der
lebensgefährte darauf reagiert als sie
an diesem morgen sehr früh
wahrscheinlich mit dem
durchsuchungsbeschluss in der hand bei
ihm auf der matte standen unter
lebensgefährte hat hat das akzeptiert
mit beschluss aber er war natürlich
maximal überrascht ja ganz klar es war
ja auch nicht müssen dass hier zwei
leute an der tür geklingelt haben
sondern da kamen ja drei lkws mit
material drei tage lang sind die
ermittler im haus und stellen es
komplett auf den kopf überall wird
gründlich nachgeschaut mit
spezialgeräten nach hohlräumen geforscht
bei der suche nach skelettierten knochen
helfen speziell ausgebildete spürhunde
im mai 2018 rückt die polizei mit einem
großaufgebot hier in der kellergasse an
die ganze straße wird hat den
durchgangsverkehr gesperrt gerade mal
der bus darf noch passieren die
spezialisten rücken erfolglos ab freddy
kann nichts nachgewiesen werden die
ermittlungen wegen totschlags werden
eingestellt der fall wird zum cold case
heidis ehemaliger lebensgefährte lebt
heute als frührentner nur 50 kilometer
entfernt es gibt im moment keine
hinweise keine spur mehr die noch offen
sind die zu ermitteln wäre anvisieren
lag das auch an ihnen dass das so ein
fall sagen so ein solch sich auftut und
jemand darin verschwindet und das nicht
klar war es nicht greifbar ist für sich
wie sehr macht ihnen das zu schaffen
also der fall die dannhäuser ist
wirklich ein fall der mir sehr zu
schaffen macht und ich werde solange ich
hier dieser dienststelle diesen job
macht an diesem fall dranbleiben das
kann ich versichern weil weil ich mir
das auch als lebensaufgabe geschrieben
habe diesen fall zu klären ich bitte sie
wenn sie irgendwelche feststellungen
gemacht haben die zum auffinden der
heidi dannhäuser führen wenn sie sich an
eine polizeidienststelle und geben sie
das von sich aus bekannt noch eine
eindringliche frage an euch da draußen
wer weiß über den folgenden sachverhalt
etwas im zusammenhang mit der
zwangsversteigerung des hauses findet
sich eine notiz auf dem zettel steht
costa del sol in heidis handschrift das
ist kein beweis für irgend etwas
konkretes aber
ist heidi vielleicht dort in ihrem
traumland mit den weißen stränden
untergetaucht immerhin wohnen laut
statistik noch 140 1000 deutsche in
spanien für die schwestern ist diese
vage möglichkeit kaum vorstellbar
die kripo geht auch dieser spur nach
bislang ohne ergebnis und für folgende
sind dies gibt es ebenfalls keine
handfesten belege unter den notizen
heidis findet die schwestern den namen
eines klassischen
wollte heidi ihr aussehen verändern
[Musik]
petra und stefanie wünschen sich dass
heidis verschwinden aufgeklärt wird und
vor allem dass ihre schwester doch noch
lebt
hier nochmal die wichtigsten
informationen zum fall zusammengefasst
heidi dannhäuser verschwand in der nacht
von 13 auf den vierzehnten november 2013
im nürnberger stadtteil fischbach sie
ist 1 meter 64 groß hat blonde
schulterlange haare zuletzt war sie
vermutlich mit einer dunklen jogginghose
und weiß rosa turnschuhen bekleidet
informationen und hinweise die zur
klärung des vermisstenfalls beitragen
können nimmt die polizei in nürnberg
oder jede andere polizeidienststelle
entgegen
heidis familie hat dafür eine belohnung
von 8000 euro ausgesetzt
danke dass ihr wieder dabei war bei
dieser episode von tatort deutschland
das letzte wort in diesem podcast hat
heidis schwester petra bis zum nächsten
mal skyeurope
[Musik]
heidi wenn du irgendwo bis wir vermissen
dich so so sehr wenn du irgendwo bizkit
sein lebenszeichen wir drücken dich
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios projektleitung
simone terbrack produktion fabian
schaeffler drehbuch lutz neumann und
stefan netzeband redaktion bild jörg
völkerling
stefan lenze